guess who knew about climate change
decades before most people had even
heard of it
ExxonMobil one of the world's biggest
oil companies they knew this from their
own research back in 1977 ironic because
now they're one of the leading opponents
of climate change science in fact some
in the oil industry had known about
climate change even earlier and what
they found led them to make pretty
accurate predictions about what we're
seeing today that the world is getting
warmer ice caps are melting and the
climate is changing thing is all that is
caused by what makes Exxon money
extracting and burning fossil fuels this
information was published but there
wasn't that much public awareness about
the dangers of climate change back then
so Exxon Mobil carried on extracting and
selling oil becoming one of the biggest
corporations in the world but by the
time the world did start paying
attention to the effects carbon
emissions were having on the planet
Exxon Mobil switched from being on the
cutting edge of climate change science
to being one of the two biggest doubters
how by employing tactics used by the
tobacco industry they spent big on
campaign contributions and lobbying
paying lobbyists 61 million dollars
between 1998 and 2005 and they get their
money's worth Exxon Mobil played a big
role in the Bush administration's
decision to drop the Kyoto climate
Protocol they also actively fund a
network of think tanks and researchers
that challenge is a scientific consensus
around climate change between 1998 and
2014 they spent 30 million dollars on
these organizations which worked to
create a sense of uncertainty about the
science among the public and that means
less pressure on the government to
regulate the oil industry given the fact
that Exxon Mobil products produce more
emissions than some entire countries it
makes sense they'd want to maintain that
uncertainty and while oil has been a big
factor in global development over the
last century spreading doubt about
science to protect profits is gonna cost
us all in the long run so just as we
took the tobacco industry to task for
denying the health risks of smoking
shouldn't we do the same with Exxon
Mobil
climate change